[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILLIPO MADELLA: Welcome
to "Architecting Startups
with Google Cloud," where we
showcase our startup customers
and how they are
architecting and deploying
their production-ready
applications with GCP.
I'm Fillipo Madella, and I lead
one of the custom engineering
teams that is
focused on startups.
Today, I'm happy to
welcome Edwin Margulies.
He's the CEO of Thrio, which
is an AI-powered contact
center as a service platform
that is using a lot of our GCP
solutions.
Very happy to chat with you
today, Edwin, and welcome.
EDWIN MARGULIES:
Thanks, Fillipo,
for the kind introduction.
Hi, everyone.
I'm very happy to chat
with you about Thrio today.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Perfect.
So Edwin, before we start,
just to set some context here,
just today, just this
morning, I spent a lot
of time trying to
contact this company
and just to solve some
issues, like as a consumer.
It was like one hour and a
half, going from their chatbot
to the phone call, and then
transferred between agents,
and me having to give
all the background.
So it was a little
bit frustrating.
So I just wanted to share that,
because that kind of helps us
on our conversation.
So tell us a little
bit about Thrio
and how Thrio is trying to
solve these type of issues
today for customers.
EDWIN MARGULIES: Sure.
Well, just like customer
service problems
you were talking about
earlier, companies
have challenges because
they unknowingly create
friction for their customers.
Thrio has a mission to
remove as much friction
as possible from customer
service transactions.
Today, customers are tired of
bots that don't help and hold
times that are too long and
having to repeat themselves
over and over.
So we use Google GCP to
solve these problems,
with a careful balance of
human assistance coupled
with automation.
This careful balance--
it's made possible
with the liberal
use of Google AI.
We help brands to focus on
smooth customer journeys.
We do this by giving customers
choices, maintaining context,
and using automation
when it's needed.
These choices include
the ability for customers
to communicate the way
they want to communicate.
For example, they can choose
SMS, chat, social media, bots,
email, and, of course, voice.
All of this is done with
a seamless transition
between different
communication channels.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Oh
well, so thank you
for that introduction.
I'm just curious, does the
platform also handle presales,
like sales leads
intake, or is it
more focused on customer
service type of channels?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Oh, that's
a great question, Fillipo.
Well, yeah, absolutely we
handle service and also sales.
In fact, with Thrio,
brand managers
can orchestrate just about
anything, from lead capture,
to sales qualification,
scheduling, product reg,
sentiment feedback, just
countless workflows.
And all of these
omnichannel transactions
are hosted in Google GCP.
In fact, we use GCP and Google
AI and our own microservices
as part of a digital
turnstile, gracefully pivoting
from one form of
communication to another.
And we also maintain
context from channel
to channel so customers don't
have to repeat themselves.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK,
so digital turnstile.
That's interesting.
I like the analogy.
And, like I mentioned,
I know you're
using a lot of our solutions.
So can we go a
little bit deeper now
on how you're using GCP overall?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Sure.
Well, the idea behind
this digital turnstile
is primarily about--
let's call it orchestration.
You see, we're kind
of at the center
of a vast set of processes, data
sets, AI resources, customer
touchpoints.
So the Thrio
application orchestrates
all that data and communications
flowing in and out.
So at the very heart of this
so-called digital turnstile
is our built-in workflow engine.
It touches every
single transaction
so we can add all kinds
of value on a transaction
by transaction basis.
In fact, it's the
workflow engine
that decides if the
transaction requires
special treatment, such as
Google language translation
or Google data loss protection.
So Google GCP
allows us to deliver
all of this on a global
scale with high reliability
and security built right in.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Well, perfect.
Thank you.
So can we go now a little
bit deeper, actually
break down a little bit
of your architecture?
Can you probably cover it a
little bit how are the main--
what are the main components
within your architecture today?
EDWIN MARGULIES: OK, sure.
Well, there are different
aspects of Thrio's architecture
that all lead to this uptime
and scalability we talked about.
There are three core
Google GCP clusters
in what we call the internal
part of Thrio's architecture.
There are also three
Google support clusters
we'll address a
little bit later.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK, so you
mentioned three within part
of the core clusters.
EDWIN MARGULIES: Sure.
Now they're the provider
cluster, the Thrio application
cluster, and the
telephony cluster.
So, first, the
provider cluster is
used to orchestrate
microservices
and to do software updates.
Kubernetes is at the heart
of that orchestration.
The provider cluster also
handles authentications
and load balancing.
Now the second is that
Thrio Application cluster.
It houses microservices that
are application-specific.
For example, multiple
instances of chat servers,
workflow service, email,
scheduling services,
to name a few.
All of these services
communicate over
a common IP messaging
bus and all are
orchestrated using Kubernetes.
And the third is the
telephony cluster.
And it houses
microservices, but these
are specialized for functions
like phone calls, conferencing,
recording, and
WebRTC connections
to contact center agents
that are using Google Chrome.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK,
so you also mentioned,
as part of the core services,
you touched on the AI portion.
I'm not seeing necessarily this
within these specific clusters.
So do you have other
supporting clusters outside,
which AI would be part of it?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Oh yes.
In addition to those three
core Google GCP clusters
we've talked about,
there's also what
I call the Google
support clusters that
are part of the architecture.
And we use these to connect
services cloud to cloud.
They include the Google
operations cluster,
the Google analytics cluster,
and the Google AI cluster.
So the Google operations
cluster houses all kinds
of essential services, such
as Google Cloud Monitoring
and Google Cloud Logging.
The Google analytics cluster
is where Google BigQuery
and Google Cloud Storage live.
The Google AI cluster is where
we access all the Google AI
goodies, like Google Cloud
Natural Language, Dialogflow,
Cloud Speech to Text, Data Loss
Prevention, and Google Cloud
Language Translation.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK, and how do
these supporting customers now
communicate back or connect
to your main core cluster?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Right.
So, basically, we do
that with workflows
that are managed by our robotic
process automation and workflow
engine.
And these are in the
application cluster
that we mentioned before.
For example, when
a call ends, we
can automatically send
follow up SMSes to a customer
or do fulfillment or
callback scheduling.
This automation allows agents
to do wrap-up tasks very quickly
before going on to
the next transaction.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Interesting.
So I think part of the core
cluster that you mentioned,
you touched on the
name microservices
as you were talking about
the digital turnstile analogy
and mentioned, of
course, GKE, Kubernetes.
And I would like
to understand, how
was the adoption for
your team of Kubernetes
and the microservices type
of architecture in general?
How is your experience so far?
EDWIN MARGULIES:
Well, let me tell you
that Kubernetes was
a welcome addition
to the mix of our architecture.
The need for containerization
and orchestration
was a very big part of
our architectural decision
and design.
So GKE makes the
replication of services
and distribution of new
software very straightforward.
In the past, the
Thrio team members
did this with
proprietary software
that took many years
for us to develop.
With Google GCP and
Kubernetes, however, we're
able to manage many different
clusters all around the world
with great ease.
The amount of labor required
to manage the network
is easily less than
half of what it
was with previous
architectures that we designed.
Now, with Google GCP, it is
also easy to scale, up or down,
depending on seasonal traffic
loads and high peak demands.
And adding capacity
is now more automated,
depending on the anticipated
load in a region.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Wow.
As a customer engineer myself,
as a solutions architect,
I love to hear time savings,
scalability, and, of course,
the more reliability
and ease of use.
So let's talk a
little bit now about--
I think in our
previous conversations,
you actually mentioned
one interesting thing,
that currently, your platform
has no window for maintenance.
So always, 24/7, your
application is alive.
So can you tell us a
little bit more about that?
How did you eliminate that
maintenance window using GCP?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Yes.
Well, we love using Google
GCP and especially Kubernetes
because it helps
us deliver service
with zero maintenance windows.
It's no small feat.
Thrio's founding team are
world-class architects
who have built modern
CCaaS platforms
over the past several decades.
And we ourselves had
to build a lot of tools
in earlier platforms for
intra-process communication,
orchestration, and redundancy.
In fact, our larger service
provider customers really
care about this, especially
for their clients
who run three shifts.
Of course, this is
enabled in large part
because of Kubernetes.
The clear benefit of
zero maintenance windows
is good old fashioned
business continuity.
No business wants to be
shut down or held hostage
by software that
requires downtime.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Yeah.
I actually think would
be useful to actually go
a little bit deeper
on that workflow
that we were mentioning
of your application
and how these parts
connect together.
Usually, when I'm
talking to a customer
to understand
their architecture,
what I actually ask the customer
is their customer journey.
So maybe that's a good way
for us to provide this prompt.
So if you were to describe
a usual customer journey,
could you walk us through
a customer journey
where some of these
multiple channels,
and how that turnstile
happens behind the scenes?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Sure.
Here's an example of
a customer journey
that illustrates how Thrio
leverages Google GCP and Google
AI.
First, a customer connects
to a Google Dialogflow bot
and will later escalate from
that bot to a live agent--
a live agent chat,
that is-- and, finally,
to a live phone call that
gets recorded and transcribed.
So let's see how that works.
So, first, a customer
goes to a website
and they click on a
bot avatar to start
a self-service interaction.
Here, of course, we
use Google Dialogflow.
Second, a secure
connection is established
between the website
where the bot surfaces
and the Thrio environment.
Here, the Google Load
Balancer and Provider Services
connect to the appropriate
resources inside of our Thrio
application cluster.
And then, third, the Thrio
Application cluster services
look up associated journey
information for the target
landing page on the website.
And it loads other information
from the Google BigQuery
database, and then engages
with Google Cloud AutoML text
to analyze customer intent.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK, Edwin,
so what if now the customer
does not want to talk to
the automated-- to the bot?
So they want to just
transfer and chat
with a live agent on that
specific chat via text.
How does your
platform handle that?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Sure.
Well, based on that
scenario, a customer
can escalate to a
human-based chat
when they're done with
Google Dialogflow.
Essentially, all
the customer needs
to do is type the word agent
or give me a live person
or something related to that, or
click on the live agent avatar.
Then we automatically engage the
Thrio chat server in the Thrio
application cluster.
Next, we do a database
lookup in Google BigQuery
and also check the intelligent
router for available agents
to connect to--
that is, the ones
who are properly
skilled to help that
particular customer.
And we use Google
Cloud AutoML text
to help with the
classification so we can then
do the automated routing in
a very quick and professional
way.
Finally, the Thrio chat server
in the Thrio application
cluster sets up a
channel with a live agent
after notifying the agent
of the chat request.
And then information from the
Google Dialogflow bot session
is sent to the agent's screen
so the agent can continue
the dialogue with the
customer while seeing
the context of the previous
session with the bot,
therefore eliminating
the need for the customer
to have to repeat themselves.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK.
The last part now
that I'm curious,
now you're talking to this
human agent on the chat.
And then, for some reason,
you need to go from the chat
now to a phone call.
Is that possible?
And, if so, how is that
handled in the backend?
EDWIN MARGULIES: OK, well,
that would make for the second
cross-channel escalation
in this customer journey--
the first one being the
escalation from the Dialogflow
bot to a live agent
chat, and the second
being a switch
from chat to phone.
But we can handle all
of that, not a problem.
In this case, the agent views
the customer contact record
and sees the
customer's phone number
retrieved from Google BigQuery.
Now the agent can
terminate the chat
and simply click
on the phone number
with her mouse to
call the customer.
In reaction to that
click made by the agent,
the media controllers in
the application cluster
send call setup information
to the telephony cluster,
which, in turn,
establishes a phone call
leg with the customer via
regular telephone network.
And then the agent is patched
into the call via WebRTC--
that is, a WebRTC
connector in Google Chrome.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK.
And I'm assuming when you're
having these conversations,
I know that they're most
likely being transcripted
to be either saved
on your system
or as part of your
analytics workflows.
So is that something that
your platform does today,
and are you using any of
our solutions to do that?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Oh, sure.
Well, an agent or a
Google Dialogflow IVR
can ask permission to record
a call for quality purposes.
And, with that permission,
recordings are enabled.
So in this case, an agent
activates the recording
with a button in the
Thrio UI using Chrome,
and this sends a signal to the
Google application cluster,
which in turn tells
the telephony cluster
to begin recording.
Afterwards, the recording is
stored in Google Cloud Storage.
Also, the Thrio Workflow engine
in the application cluster
causes the recording to be
streamed to the Google AI
cluster so we can call upon
Google Cloud Speech to Text.
The resulting
transcription of the call
is also sent to
Google Cloud Storage.
FILLIPO MADELLA: And do
you do any type of analysis
on these calls?
For example, if there's any
concerns within the text,
like you want to
evaluate the quality,
or you want to escalate
to a supervisor
based on what was
said on the call,
do you do any sort of
analysis on what was said?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Oh, sure.
In fact, based on the parameters
of a customer journey,
the Google Cloud
Speech to Text is
used to take the transcribed
text and stream it
to Google AutoML Natural
Language for analysis
of compliance phrases.
The results are then returned to
the Thrio application cluster.
And supervisors
can get involved,
because the User Service
in the application cluster
sends a live agent
dashboard alarm
to the supervisor indicating
that the agent missed
a compliance phrase while
talking with the customer.
The supervisor then reviews the
transcript and sees the misses.
Now the supervisor can
start a one-on-one chat
with the agent to coach
the agent on the compliance
phrases that were missed.
And this is set up using our
chat service in the application
cluster and company directory.
Look, this is just one of
hundreds of flexible customer
journeys that can be
achieved using Thrio.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
OK, well, thank you.
I'm curious now
on the data piece.
Like I mentioned,
this is something
that I'm imagining you
are processing hundreds
of thousands, if not millions.
You mentioned you have a
global scale, global reach.
So what do you do with all
the information, not just
the calls, but the
metadata from these calls--
what do you do today with that?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Sure.
Well, we use Google BigQuery
to house all transaction
histories.
It's used for
analytics, dashboards,
special integrations
with other systems.
BigQuery has helped tremendously
with Thrio partners,
such as larger service providers
and BPOs who need direct access
to their own data.
In these larger service
provider scenarios,
a Thrio partner may
have their own instance
of Google BigQuery running.
The partner will give
Thrio permissions,
via Google Security
Token Service,
to read and write to
the database-- that is,
their database.
Customers are able to run
their own queries that
are unique to their business.
And, in addition, they
can run the canned reports
that Thrio has written, as well.
FILLIPO MADELLA: Wow.
It's a very unique
use case, where
you're allowing your customers,
almost like using this Titanic
scenario with BigQuery, allowing
them to query their own data.
Did you have any challenges
implementing the solution,
something that you could share?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Sure.
Well, at first,
the extent to which
customers would be
running their own queries
would affect other customers,
because the spirit of CCaaS
is that it's a shared
tenancy arrangement where
you achieve economy of
scale with shared use.
So, in the beginning,
that shared use
did provide some challenges.
So we overcame this
lopsided nature
of some of the larger
customer resource
allocations by segmenting
the architecture
with separate hosted instances
of Google BigQuery for larger
service providers.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK.
And if you were to do
any future enhancements
to your architecture, do you
have any plans or something
that you could share with
those watching a little bit?
What's something that
is on your roadmap?
EDWIN MARGULIES: Yeah.
I would say that we'll
continue to expand
our suite of AI-based
services based on Google AI.
At present, we offer Google Data
Loss Protection, Dialogflow,
AI-based classification,
Google Sentiment Analysis,
Google Speech to
Text, Text to Speech,
Google Natural Language.
So our focus in 2022 will be
more enhancements to Google
Agent Assist technology to
augment our own robotic process
automation.
FILLIPO MADELLA: OK.
Certainly a lot of our
menu there included.
And, just to wrap it up,
how can people watching
learn more about Thrio?
EDWIN MARGULIES: OK, sure.
Well, the best place
to go is thrio.com.
That's T-H-R-I-O. And there's
a lot of information in there
about how we use Google and
all the applications that we
provide.
FILLIPO MADELLA:
You just saw how
Thrio is able to host global
applications with ease using
GKE, to store and analyze
millions of records
using Google BigQuery, and also
provide an intelligent contact
center as a service,
all powered by Google AI
to serve their global customers
and BPO needs around the world.
If you found this
video helpful and you
want to watch more "Architecting
with Google Cloud" videos,
please make sure that
you like this video
and subscribe to
our YouTube channel.